رافقت الابن العرب منذ الاف السنين الى
اليوم في حضاره خالده
الدوله السعوديه استمر اعتماد الانسان على
الابل في حله وترحاله فهي مصدر غذائه
وقوته واصبح الناس فيما بعد يعتزون بها
ويتباهونا بجمالها وها هنا نحن الان في
منطقه سياهد التي اقيم بها مهرجان الملك
عبد العزيز للابل يهدف هذا المهرجان الى
ترسيخ الاهتمام بالابل بوصفها موروثا
اصيلا في السعوديه والتعاون في نشر هذه
الثقافه ودعمها على مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
من بين اثنين وثلاثين مشاركا عربيا
اوروبيا شارك البريطانيه
الحصول على لقب صوت المنظمه الدوليه للابن
[موسيقى]
دنيس اذا ممكن تحدثنا اكثر عن مشاركتك في
مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز الابل وما الذي
يشجعك ان تشارك في هذا المهرجان
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
سبع سنوات
طلاب حبيبي
[موسيقى]
او الاصوات او النغمات التي يمكن ان
نسمعها بين الابل وصاحبه
ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله نمبر وان كثير
[موسيقى]
مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز للابل لم يترك
بصمه تراثيه وثقافيه على مستوى المجتمع
السعودي فقط فلم تبدا اثره على مستوى
العالم
العنود العبدلي صباح العربيه الرياض
[موسيقى]